so when it comes to toxic fandom let's
for the moment set aside the issue of
deliberately infiltrating fan spaces in
order to rile up young white men into
anger against anything that does not
cater specifically to them which yes is
the thing that happens it's been
documented but for the moment set that
aside i think there's a core thing at
the heart of the
just attitude of fandoms right now that
is really contributing to a lot of the
problems because back in the day which i
can say because i'm old like just
knowing that a lot of people were fans
you wouldn't necessarily get to interact
with them enough to get all the details
of what was at the heart of their fandom
but these days when everyone has a
platform everyone has access to
everybody's ideas now we know the
reasons that people like something and
it doesn't seem like it's enough that
you just both like the same thing
you have to like it for the same reasons
and now suddenly there are wrong ways to
like something and you're also supposed
to dislike
the same things about it if you think
there are problems